I don't know which was the first of
Sofia Lorenz films that I saw it could
have been something as magical as blind
as dolphin it could have been something
as delightful as houseboat with Cary
Grant it could have been two women or
marriage Italian style but it's she has
always been a very formidable presence
one thing has always seemed to have been
with us like Picasso or Marlon Brando or
William Wyler somebody who is a great
artist and a great social presence that
has helped to find periods of our own
lives by who we were when we first saw
her can you remember what it was like
the first time you saw Sophia Loren film
whether it was dubbed in English or
subtitled from its Italian or in English
itself was it something big and huge
like El Cid or as was it something in
black and white like the films she made
with mozzarella Maserati whatever it was
even though I particularly might have
been a nine or a 12 or a 17 year old kid
I felt as though I was seeing something
that I recognized in the films that
Sophia Loren was appearing in you know
it's great to know now that films are
going to last forever
in whatever form they're going to be
showing up and on a screen in front of
us generations to come for thousands of
years are going to be able to rediscover
Sophia Loren and have defined for them
once again what grace beauty and
artistry is in the work of her films she
is a an example of how making motion
pictures can forever define who we are
at a specific point in time as well as
forever you know I wish I could be in
the in the room tonight to help honor
you Sophia with the attention you so
richly deserved Billy Crystal you are
one lucky man it is also fitting and
proper that the Academy holds this event
for you Sophia
not just so that the Academy can honor
you for your great work and your great
effect and the great affection that we
have for you
you haven't just touched the art of
cinema you haven't just made the world
of making movies better you have
actually made our lives better you are
forever an example of all the things a
true artist strives to be which is
timeless beautiful and authentically
real so feel our in I don't speak
Italian but I know this
you are unmeet though you are a myth but
more than just a myth in the Italian
sense of the word you are a life force
that infects us all every day and makes
life that much better
we love you Sofia thank you so much and
enjoy this magnificent evening
you